hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled keynote presentation choosing
wisely
lab utilization first steps addressing
the low hanging fruit
this webinar is part of the clinical
diagnostics and research virtual event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i now present today's speaker dr
jeanne
kellum a professor of laboratory
medicine and pathobiology at the
university of toronto and the director
of laboratory
utilization at sunnybrook health
sciences
center in toronto for a complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr kellum welcome
you may now begin your presentation okay
thanks susie for that
lovely introduction and i'm excited to
be here and to share
um all the efforts we've done at our
center to try and improve our laboratory
utilization
so just for disclosure i am a uh also a
transfusion medicine researcher and i do
a lot of research to do with uh
utilization of blood products and
hence receive funding from new numerous
organizations
so i have four objectives for you today
first is to help you identify areas of
inefficiency
in the lab that need improving do
identify tests that are commonly
overused that you might want to go after
and evaluate system changes necessary to
bring that utilization down
and then lastly how to assess how your
system changes were they successful or
not or were there any unintended
consequences of those
the flow of this talk is going to go
through first talking about strategies
to figure out where you start your
next or your first choosing wisely
project
and then i'm going to talk about three
quality improvement projects
that we did at sunnybrook we've done
many but these three really highlight
different strategies that you need to
use depending on what the problem is
so i'm going to talk about how we
reduced our ast
and urea testing and eventually that
project
related to stopping the computer from
ordering tests that the doctors weren't
even ordering or wanted
i'm going to talk about this stopping
the ck used for cardiac
injury and for this we had to convince
the doctors that they didn't need it
they actually
wanted it but the system was also
helping to order it
and then lastly the b12 it was a
completely different problem the doctors
were ordering duplicate tests because
they couldn't see that the patient had a
previous test
and so all these three things needed
slightly different solutions so i'm
going to go through what we did for them
but before we go to that let's talk
about where you should start
so choosing wisely was started by the
american
um board of internal medicine
and has been widely successful and
duplicated across the whole planet
so you can see there we have choosing
wisely canada even within canada we have
provinces that have their own special
programs
but there's choosing wisely australia
the uk
europe um and so really everybody's
jumped on this bag
wagon and the mission of all of these is
to start conversations between patients
and clinicians about what tests they
actually need
and the mission of their organization is
to choose care
that's supported by the evidence there's
no duplication of tests
the testing doesn't result in
unnecessary harm and all the tests are
truly necessary
the choosing wisely statements a lot of
people didn't like them because they all
started with
don't but really it sends the messages
like don't do this test in this
situation
so some of the strategies that you might
think about is
um to get this going is making sure that
you've got the right team of people
around you
you can't do this solely just with an
intro laboratory team you need
lots of team members outside on the
clinical side
you need access to data somebody to get
that to you then you need somebody to
analyze it
and i cannot stress the importance of
having a professional statistician
who can analyze your data and think
about it differently than maybe you
might think about it
and to generate really great run charts
for you to be able to use
for your presentations at your medical
advisory committee
to your clinical teams or when you
publish your
successes in a journal you need the list
of the choosing wisely lab related items
that have been out put out by all these
different organizations so you can
really run through them and think um
i've already done that we don't have to
worry about this oh but we haven't done
anything about that that's a big problem
at my hospital let's focus on that you
need to look at publications
of quality improvement projects for the
laboratory from other centers so you
learn from their failures as well as
their successes because they might give
you some ideas about how you might do it
at your hospital
and then lastly if you say you choose a
test you know say you're going to focus
on
vitamin b12 testing you got to pull out
all the guidelines and systematic
reviews about that
so you're certain that you've got really
solid evidence to convince your doctors
that they can change their lab ordering
practice
and then really lastly to lead this
you've got to be super energetic
everybody's going to come to you and say
oh that's going to be a lot of work
that's not going to work here um i've
got too many other things on my plate
but if you could
you know provide a lot of energy you're
going to be able to convince people to
do things they probably didn't think
uh were possible so just an example of
getting the right team
this is the team we put together when we
decided that we had to address
the use of the ast test and the blood
urea nitrogen test
and so we put together a big team so i
didn't have to do this all by myself
so i had a resident who did a lot of the
uh
background work on researching when
these tests
actually were necessary i got a
general internist who also has a
laboratory appointment because he really
understood
how the lab worked and also how the
clinicians were thinking
i got a general internist who is in
charge of
our information system for our
electronic medical record
because he understood how the computer
thought and how we could manipulate the
computer
to get the ordering practice better i
involved the head of our choosing wisely
program
for our whole hospital not just to do
with the lab but you know really the
whole hospital to get her buy-in
and then we got a nephrologist because
we needed that for the
you know the expert content knowledge
for the urea and then a
gastroenterologist for the asp
we had a family physician because the
family docs were ordering a lot of these
tests unnecessarily so he could do a lot
of that education for me
and probably two of the most important
people we had an i.t person from the lab
to get us our data and to analyze it
and then we had a bsc student who did it
as a research project
and she did all the grunt work for me of
changing all the order sets and the
computer order sets
uh to make this happen so you really
need a big big team
and you need access to data um and so we
worked with our decision supporter or
hospital to generate just a little
portal where we could go in
and we could access the data and look at
you know ordering test volumes by doctor
by location by groups of locations like
inpatient outpatient
to really help us figure out okay where
do we need to start
and this little portal allows us to look
at who's ordering the test
most of the time the doctors actually
aren't ordering the test they're being
ordered by order groups order sets
but it really tells you who you need to
go talk to to figure out
how how does this test get ordered
because you're going to be pretty
certain that
it's actually not being ordered by the
docs and then by location
is it a whole hospital-wide problem that
you have to address or is it maybe just
like three locations you got to focus on
and you need access to a satisfaction i
have an amazing statistician that does
all of my blood related research as well
as my uh
utilization research but she looks at
the data in ways that you know i would
never look at
and so on our most recent report that we
got out on our b12
uh uh intervention study
she actually generated a kaplan-meier
curve for the survival
at my hospital uh without a repeat b12
level
um and so that she looked at the data in
ways i would never have looked at and so
i can't stress again the importance of
having a statistician on your team
and i had my my assistant
come through and cut and paste from
every choosing wisely statement for
every country
that we could find it online so that i
had this long list
of the tests which group was putting out
the statement and what was the fine
print under that statement
so we could go back to our choosing
wisely team and decide okay where do we
start which ones have we done which ones
we haven't done
and this gave me a really great starting
point so i think that this is kind of a
great exercise
as you go through your different
projects
and then you got to look at the
publications you're not going to be able
to do this without evidence you know
when we went to look at
uh fixing the vitamin d you know
it was clear that vitamin d
supplementation let's like not even talk
about testing yet but just
taking vitamin d supplements has really
never been proved to change any outcome
and you can go to the systematic reviews
and boy
that's surprising it doesn't change
fracture rates it doesn't change
um mobility issues and elderly people
it doesn't change mortality let alone
does it change um uh uh uh if you know
what their
your vitamin t level is um if
supplementation doesn't work
in a you know in a population based way
we do know that actually vitamin d is
harmful because we know it
causes kidney stones but we can't find
any clear benefit at a population level
so really important to go after the
guidelines but also at the same time
pull up the literature on quality
improvement projects relating to vitamin
d so i've just
pasted three different titles of people
that looked at vitamin d
to try and control the use and it's
really important to read through those
really read the methods in depth to
understand how they did it because it's
going to give you great ideas about how
you're going to do it
okay and so at the end of that you have
to think okay where am i going to start
you know are you going to start with
just one test and really focus on one
test are you going to
look at a group of tests um are you
going to look at the most expensive test
because that's going to make your
vp of fiance super happy are you going
to look at send outs they tend to cost
us a lot of money and there's a lot more
logistics of sending out samples for us
in canada we also have out of country
tests they cost us
a lot of money and it's you know even
expensive to
ship the sample are you going to look at
the frequency of repeat tests like a
test within a certain duration
of a normal test result are you going to
look at what the ministry of health so
in our country we have the ministry of
health that you know kind of oversees
how we're doing and they're watching
uh the laboratory tests that are being
done at every hospital and they put out
a list of
their kind of you know urgent quality
improvement projects they want us to get
on
are you gonna look at efficiency not
just you know utilization but
you know can we get the test out faster
and turn around better
and then my biggest beef is paper we use
so much
paper uh within many of our laboratories
this is just the back corner
in our blood bank and to the amount of
paper that gets sent out for
off-site storage for many years and i
think
we also need to address this as lots of
areas
for utilization not just test
utilization but also efficiencies paper
etc
so as i said before uh the ministry of
health this is the
the most recent list that was sent to us
from a utilization point of view
um and the mystery of health asks us do
you do any of these wrong things
and so when we looked at this list back
in 2017 um
four of the five things that they asked
us related to lab testing
and you can see there in the you know
the x with the green we'd done one of
them we got rid of the folate testing so
we've at least done one of the four
lab ones but the other three we
continued to do so
we still in the emerge even though we
decoupled the inr and the ptt from
ordering
they'd regroup them in the emergency
department so we're working on fixing
this
we were still using the ck for diagnosis
of a heart attack
and in patients we're generally getting
daily laboratory tests we've been
working on this as well we have like
when you go to log
in to our electronic medical record
there
for many months there's this big banner
to say don't order more than three days
in advance
trying to get people to just think short
term on their frequency of their
laboratory testing
i think in the long run we have to go to
you don't order tests for more than one
day
but right now we're focusing on three
days
okay and if all else fails and you can't
figure out where you're going to start
really helpful to me is drinking a lot
of coffee i spent a lot of time in the
coffee lineup talking to my clinicians
and they tell me oh genie you've got to
fix you know we're ordering so many crps
in our icu you need to fix this
or we're doing too many esrs or
cks in the cbi cu and so
sitting down and chatting with them is
super helpful in helping me kind of
figure out where do we go next
okay so now i'm going to transition and
i'm going to talk about
three uh analytes that we decided
three projects that we decided to focus
on so the first one
um uh was we decided to focus on
the urea and the ast and the reason for
this is
there were the urea was one of the most
common tests after the cbc that was done
at my hospital
um uh so there's lots of room for
improvement
not a single physician was putting up
any roadblocks to change
they kept saying oh my god goodness you
need to fix this doc's were stopping
me in the hallway and saying genie we're
ordering way too many of these tests
can't you somehow figure out how to get
the computers to stop ordering these and
my nephrology and gastroenterology
colleagues were more than willing to
help me as long as at the meetings i
brought the coffee and they didn't have
to do a lot of work they just had to
provide their expert in
input and for these two analytes
most of the tests were not being ordered
by the doctors they were being ordered
by the computer system
in such a way that it was going to be
easier to fix them
so the first thing that i did was i had
my general internal
resident uh come up with by looking at
the literature when we thought it was
appropriate to do an ast
generally as a single measure you would
never do an ast daily in a patient
because an alt is a much better
reflection of liver injury
and then same thing for the urea you
know these tests are still good tests
when they're done in the right patient
setting
with the right frequency you know for
example
um the ast is used in looking at scoring
systems for
liver injury uh for hepatic fibrosis
it's done as a single test a single
ratio
you don't need this ratio done every day
and for urea
you know for example when you're on
dialysis the recommendations and the
guidelines is that every six weeks you
should have a urea clearance test so you
the patients all get two ureas on the
same day um but that should only be done
once a month once every six weeks
so there are isolated situations where
you might do these and then we use this
to promote education
education alone isn't going to change
anything at your hospital but it's kind
of a core part of it people need to
understand why you're changing
the rules when they've always ordered an
ast an
alt and an alp and a billy rubin all
together why'd you take one of them out
i just need to know why
next thing we did was we looked at the
data so
this is a total number of tests
in 2017 and we looked at which doctor
type was ordering the asp and the urea
and you can see there for the ast which
is really a test of the liver
you know it should be mostly ordered by
gastroenterologists and not a single
gastroenterologist came up on the top 15
left
so obviously right there there's a
problem and you can see the second most
common person that was ordering the ast
was the triage nurses and that's really
odd because
you never need this test in the
emergency department
except for in really unique situations
so obviously big room for improvement
very similar findings for the urea
so the nurses in the emerge were
ordering more than 75 percent of our
urea tests so you can see right there
with just changing
the order groups for the emergency
nurses this is going to be super easy to
fix
for the urea it looked a little bit more
appropriate
you know the nephrologists were coming
up as the most common people ordering
this and that's their attending month
on the dialysis unit so there were some
better things going on with the
urea than the asp
and the next thing i had are
statistician in r
generate these great run charts if you
want to do run charts
you can do them in lots of different
platforms
but r is probably one of the best uh
platforms to do this and we had
this nice no change because of course we
hadn't done anything about the urea but
we were running about 12 000 urea tests
per month
and then we looked at our baseline for
the ast again
we hadn't intervened nothing had been
changing so we have this very
flat line of about 3 200 tests per month
so we had a great uh run-in to be able
to show a change
so then we got to work so after doing a
very detailed analysis of
how the test got ordered we had to go
after
four different locations within our
hospital ordering system to figure it
out so for
inpatients doctors could order
tests on when they admitted a patient
say with copd they would have an order
set
they could either do it in the computer
system or we had downtime paper order
sets
and so we went through all of those um
order sets and we had to change 41 of
them to remove the ast
and the bun from all of those
from those order groups a clerk would go
in
and enter the orders they would go
across to oasis
in addition the clerks and the nurses
had their own
order personalized order groups that
they could have created 20 years ago
that included the urea and the ast and
we sucked it out of there
first we sucked it out of their order
groups and then we decided at a later
point
we just disabled them you weren't
allowed to generate your own
personalized order groups because it
just was an
opportunity for people to generate bad
practice that was very difficult later
on to
to change the next thing we had to do
was figure out what to do with the
triage nurses in the emergency
department
what had been happening is the nurse
would look at the patient and they
would be presenting with chest pain they
would have a chest pain order group
in our computer system they would order
it and that would come across to our sun
quest
lab system and so we had to change all
of those order groups
for chest pain gi bleeding to take out
the ast
and the bun we actually took out other
stuff while we were in there because
we're like oh my goodness why are you
doing that test too
so we didn't actually just change these
two we changed a whole bunch of other
stuff to kind of give them a complete
refresh and then did a lot of education
with the nurses in the emergency
department just so they understood why
we were taking
these tests out
in the um outpatients so these are like
you know
patients that are at home and they come
in to see their endocrinologists and
then go to the lab
it's all done on paper which is
obviously a problem in itself that has
to be fixed at some later point
but we removed these two tests so they
don't even they're not even listed
we're trying to push them into the back
of the doctor's brain so they actually
had to actually write them out um and so
when you ask for a liver profile you
just got the alt
and the alp
and then lastly in our cancer center our
cancer center was at least you know
electronically ordering this so the
doctors were ordering it
they also had their own personalized
order groups that they could create so
if you were a
medical oncologist that saw patients
with liver cancer
you could have your ast and your urea in
your order groups but we pulled them out
on block and so there were something
like 5 000
order groups over there in our cancer
center for all our different doctors
and on a single day they all got pulled
out
[Music]
they could still order them but uh the
computer wouldn't order them they had to
actually think and it came along
obviously with a lot of education
and this is what happened so you can see
because this was a systems problem
overnight you can make a change and so
we dropped from
1200 tests per month to about 2 000
tests per month and we're currently
running about
13 of the time somebody sends a
creatinine they also send a urea so lots
of those are still appropriate some of
them are done for research tests for
clinical trials
some that are done for our urea
clearance tests so there are some of
these are appropriate but still there's
probably a little bit of room for
improvement there as well
and we had an equal amount of success
for the asc
we're actually down to now only seven
percent of the time somebody orders an
alt you get an ast and so we've had
really
remarkable success of pushing this out
of the doctor's brain
and forcing them to do the right test
and we've had nice stability over a year
after
uh this time period
and you know don't just stop there you
know publish your
data because other people can learn from
you and
um uh learn from your successes and your
failures so we published this
in bmj quality and safety
and we also um generated a banner that
went on
our what we call we're at sunnybrooks or
internet's called sunnynet
and we put a banner there um to promote
our success so all the doctors
knew um that we were having really great
success so it's
you know it starts almost like a little
story um
why you should say twice about uh before
ordering these two tests
it tells you in 2016 and january this is
how many tests were done per month
what our goal was why did we choose
these two particular tests to work
on and then just a little timeline of
like all the different things that we
did to try and fix this problem
just a little bit of education and then
at the bottom of the banner it was our
success rate
that we got a 74 reduction combined for
these two tests and the total amount of
utilization and a big thank you
um out to the clinical team for really
supporting us and doing this initiative
okay so that was the really easy one the
second one
was trying to get rid of the ck for
cardiac injury
this was a much more than it was partly
a systems problem
but a lot of the doctors particularly
are cardiologists and some of our
cardiac surgeons and
cardiovascular intensivists still loved
this test
and so this created a little bit more
work fortunately i had
dr raza who at the time was a general
internal medicine resident who wanted to
do general internal medicine
um and he worked on this project but by
the time he finished i'd converted him
into understanding that hematology was
the best sub-specialty and
in july of next year he will be one of
our hematology
residents
so um we've gotten to this dotted line
at tiny work so originally uh we had
done a ck and a ckmb
for cardiac injury and then troponin
came along and we added the troponin
without taking the other two away
we eventually were able to just stop
offering the ckmb test but they still
kept ordering the ck but we never went
to the final distance
and went straight to just a troponin
only
and so that was our challenge for this
quality improvement project
so the first thing like we did with the
first project is we looked at the data
so this is just for one month in
september and we looked at you know how
many doctors were ordering
um uh uh ck or troponin and what the
ratio was and how often they were
ordered together
so our ck to troponin ratio was running
at about 88
it was super high we didn't really have
a clue of where we needed to get this to
um but we wanted to get it below 25
um and 78 of the time these two tests
were ordered together so we were pretty
certain that they were being ordered for
cardiac injury when you really
shouldn't be and almost all the tests or
the bulk of them were coming up with a
normal test result as well
so probably some over ordering going on
just like we did for the the ast and the
urea we also looked at
well who were the top 30 doctors
ordering this um
and you can see there it was really um
just very isolated parts of the hospital
so it was a patient
in the emerge the cardiovascular icu
the icu and the cardiac war so it wasn't
we didn't have to go after the whole
hospital to fix this problem
we really had four areas that we had to
focus on
so compared to the urea and the
ast where it was the whole hospital we
had to fix this we could focus here it
wasn't being ordered by our family
doctors or our outpatient interns
and so when we met with our cardiac
and cardiac icu team they were like no
no no
no we still need this test we like this
test for six reasons
we think it helps the assessment of that
acute mi
it gives a more rapid diagnosis of
myocardial infarction
it's better at diagnosing reinforcion
after initial infarction
it's better at estimating the infarct
size so they wanted to look at the area
under the curve
that ck over time and watch it you know
resolve to normal and use that to
estimate how much of the myocardium was
injured
they thought it was a better test if you
had an mi after a cardiac procedure like
an angio
and if you had a sub-acute infarction in
fact like several days ago they thought
it was
better for detecting an old infarct so
it turned out that
none of these six things that they
believed in they were all kind of fake
news
so we really had to re-educate them to
convince them that these were not true
and at the end of the day they they
agreed that these were probably
not good but you know when i went to
them with
to get their signature to pull the ck
off of the order sets and the computer
system
for all the cardiac order sets the
answer was no no we still want this test
and we want it ordered by the computer
on every single patient
rather than picking and choosing which
patients needed this so
here i kind of hit this roadblock
but unfortunately i had been in norway
and i was giving a debate
and i was giving a debate about one
blood product over another with the
u.s military which i'm happy to say i
won
but during that i had this great idea
and i thought ah
i'm gonna challenge them to a debate so
i
emailed my chief of cardiology and i
said well let's do a debate since we
can't get a final resolution
we're gonna do a pro ck versus con ck
for myocardial injury
i'll do the con you need to get somebody
on your team to step up
the plate to debate me and 48 hours
later by the time i got back from norway
the papers were signed and they were on
my desk and we were able to pull the ck
from all their order sets
so i never ever actually had to do this
debate
and so in this quality improvement
project we did almost the same thing uh
once we got
the approval to move forward and get
them convinced of the need to do this
we obviously analyzed the data we had
wide stakeholder consultation
we removed the ck from every order group
in the computer system
every order set and then we did ongoing
monthly analysis
so we knew oh you know the cardiac word
they're still ordering it why's that
and then you know we found on our
cardiac
team that the clerks just had a little
cue card which told them when this kind
of patient was admitted these are the
tests they did and the ck was still on
that
even though we ordered it from the um
the computerized order sets
and it worked um we're now sitting at
about a third of the time they order
troponin we get a ck
we still have room for improvement and
we're still working on this but we've
made a major dent
in the ordering of ck
and one of the ways i really like to
look at these grouped together tests
that you're trying to
ungroup let's start with one of these
venn diagrams you can see there before
there was almost complete overlap
between the troponin and the ck
amount and so in the post intervention
okay i shrunk the ck they're ordering
less of them
but also less coupling of them so i
think it's a really good way
in laboratory medicine to describe how
we're using these two tests
okay we're just waiting for our code
white to finish here
so the so the third test also had a
completely
uh third project had a completely
different
um problem
so um we uh recruited
megan mclavish who wanted to do a
quality improvement project she was
another
second year internal medicine resident
one of the good things is the internal
medicine residents have to do quality
improvement projects during their
training
so paul yep and i who's our division
lead for clinical chemistry and i
have been working with her to try and
figure this out
and we actually harness the middleware
to put controls on repeats not just for
the b12 that i'm going to show you here
but simultaneously
for the hemoglobin a1c and the vitamin d
and so we were able to use the same
technique
to control multiple paths
and most of the problem that we found
was that
hospitalized patients were getting
duplicate tests for b12 because the
doctor couldn't see in the laboratory
system
that they'd already had that test two
days ago and the test result was normal
because they couldn't see it they
figured it had never been done and so
they
they ordered it again
and so when we looked at the b12
utilization
baseline we were running about 6000
tests per year
of which about eight percent were
happening in the emergency department
38 percent in their in the inpatient
locations and
about half in the outpatient locations
in the
outpatient locations it took a long time
more than six months before somebody had
a repeat test
they were doing a much better job but on
the
inpatient side the median time to your
next test was about 49 to 89 days
so it was really soon after their
previous test
and so we calculated that by putting
controls where you couldn't have a
repeat test
after a previously normal test within 12
weeks
and so uh we estimated that would that
would yield us about 8.6
improvement in our performance
and so um very similar to other projects
first we gathered information and data
and had meetings with people that were
ordering these three tests
we went to the medical advisory
committee and we got them to approve
us putting control so they couldn't have
a repeat test and so it was all done
above board it wasn't something sneaky
we did in the background
and then uh paul yep worked tirelessly
for several months
to put in all the logic in the
middleware
to make this happen and do an extensive
validation
so we didn't mess up when we went live
and then we implemented the rules in
early 2020
and so just for an example you know they
paul had to put
17 different conditions on this so you
know for example
the computer had to look and say okay
was there a previous result was it
within the last 80 days
instead of doing 90 days we gave them a
little bit of wiggle room and we said 80
days
was the test result normal and where for
normal we hit
we just you know put that at 250 which
most of us would agree is okay
we looked at the ordering location
making sure it's not being ordered by
research
if for some research um program they
need to b12 done on patients for say in
the neurology research program
they're paying for it they can still
have it and look for previous error
flags maybe the previous result wasn't
um valid and so they're reordering it to
try and get a valid result
and so there were all these different
conditions so we made sure that we
canceled the right test but didn't
cancel tests that actually need to be
done
um and then the physician in their
electronic inbox
if they ordered a test within those 80
days they get a nice little message this
test was not performed due to previous
order
within the preceding three months but
you can contact the laboratory within
five days we still have the tube and
we'll run that test for you
i'm happy to report that basically
nobody called the lab asking us to
run these tests and so uh people were
you know
okay to go back and look and see oh
there was a test i can go look at a
previous result
and then a in addition to going to the
medical advisory committee
um uh a
email message went out to all laboratory
users all the physicians to say
hey we just put controls on the b12 we
also did the controls on the vitamin d
at the same time
also allowing no repeat tests within a
certain interval
explaining why we did this what the
evidence for this
is um and as far as i know
nobody uh complained and so doctors are
really
generally buying into the fact that we
have to use our healthcare resources
more effectively otherwise you know it's
just going to cost
so much money that lots of patients
aren't going to get the care that they
need
and here's the results so this went live
as i said in january
of uh uh 2020 and you can see there
the utilization went down it went down
for a very good reason and that would be
covis
um because lots of patients don't want
to have any laboratory testing done
but you can see also there in that red
color are all the cancel tests
so where we estimated that around eight
percent um
of tests would get uh cancel we're
pretty bang on at seven point five
percent so despite covid
we're pretty bang on on what we were
going to be able to achieve with these
middleware controls
and you can see here on the
pre-intervention to the post
intervention and i'll remind you i
didn't have to do any of this analysis i
got my statistician to do it
if i had done this analysis it would
have taken me a week whereas
she could have done it in a day so you
can see there
of people that went on to have repeats
um having a repeat in the in within
three months was about 50
of the repeats um versus we dropped that
number to 9.5
having a repeat within that time period
uh so
a very effective intervention
you can also see that the median time to
re a repeat
went up dramatically
and we also as a balancing measure every
time you do a quality improvement
project
you want to think about okay what are
the downsides you know how can i cause
harm by my intervention
and so two of the things that we wanted
to look at was how many times
did we run the test when we shouldn't
you know shouldn't run the test and that
happened about 20 times it's not so bad
but we had three tests that should have
been run but that weren't run
that we're still trying to figure out
why did the computer not run them
because there was no good reason
so we're still monitoring this but
really
crucial that you monitor this the 20
that were run
um that shouldn't have been run they
were really good reasons for this
so we don't run a b12 on a saturday or
sunday
so if a doctor orders a b12 on a
saturday and then they say oh my
goodness there was no b12 result
ordered again on sunday well it still
won't get run on the sunday
they'll both be put on the analyzer to
be run on the monday
um but uh because they're being run
simultaneously there is no valid result
and both of them will come across and be
run
at the same time so as you build your
middleware rules for this really think
really carefully
of all the possible permutations and
combinations
that could go wrong uh so that this
doesn't happen um
in addition monitor for it uh so you can
sort of slowly tweak your rules
until they're just perfect
okay so now i'd like to just you know
review those objectives that we had
um and really summarize what i've talked
about
so the first thing is to identify areas
of inefficiency in your lab that need
improving
so really improv important to look at
your data
talk to your clinicians find out what
they think is an overused test at your
hospital
and look at all your different processes
and find out
what are the things that you could
harness to make change how do you order
your tests
um do you have computerized physician
order entry
um do clinicians have their own order
groups that you could modify
how would you actually be able to
harness to generate change
identifying the tests that are commonly
overused in your organization
so look through that choosing wisely
list of all the different lab tests
that people are trying to fix look at
the guidelines where's the evidence
for the the best evidence to cut out a
test
and really there's a lot of evidence for
that vitamin d
test ck the ast the urea
and sifts through different papers a lot
of people have published their successes
in their quality improvement projects
for laboratory testing even if that test
wasn't the test you're going to work on
i bet you a lot of their methodology and
how they did it
you can learn from you want to evaluate
the system changes necessary to bring
your utilization down
and so
that the computer order tests
that are ordered by the computer versus
being ordered by the doctors
which ones the doctors are ordering how
much education are you going to need to
do
to get them to change their practice and
how much of your problem is duplicate
tests tests are being run
because the doctor actually can't see
somehow in the lab system that that has
already been done
and then assessing how you know if your
system has
changed has been successful so somehow
figure out how to get
easy access to monthly data and again i
can't stress how important it is to find
a statistician that's going to work with
you
to help generate your run charts analyze
your data
help you think about uh your how your
data is going to be presented in your
papers
and in your presentations to your
hospital your clinicians your medical
advisory committee
so with that i'll stop and i'm happy to
take questions
and comments criticism thank you
and thank you dr callum for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great
questions coming in
our first question dr kellum is what
laboratory inefficiency
issues and problems do you find most of
and what problems would you say are most
important
and a priority to solve first
yeah so i don't think there's a one good
answer
for everybody and every hospital is
going to have a different
setup so i can tell you
you know when i think about my lab now
in terms of where we've gotten to
um we sort of fix all the low-hanging
fruit and my one of my biggest
um pushes right now for me is to get rid
of the paper
because to me the paper is inefficient
it creates extra workload for the
clinicians
um and so we're working on that but
that's because i'm at a different point
i've already fixed some of the other
things
so i think you need to look at your own
statistics you got to look at your own
processes
and figure out what's your top thing
don't try and start
14 different projects at the same time
just start one
two get them done reevaluate them and
move on to the next project
thank you so much that sounds like good
advice for everybody
our next question does the choosing
wisely initiative
specific guidelines and recommendations
to reduce
unnecessary expenses related to the
reduction in length of
hospital stay and also inappropriate
utilization of
high cost medications
yeah so if you look at the choosing
wisely
recommendations um they don't have a lot
of verbiage there
but there is quite a concise paragraph
on
say you know
say for blood transfusion you should not
be ordering more than one red cell at a
time
and it gives a justification as well as
some key guideline references so you
have a really good
starting point for where to start
in terms of you know unnecessary
expenses related to reduction in
length of hospital stay there actually
aren't a lot of
studies that show that by these quality
improvement projects we can reduce the
length of stay
there have been a few studies say for
example if you get less blood
transfusions you say less you know
you know a day or a half a day length of
say
drops um or if you don't do a ck
test as your routine for myocardial
injury um you stop patients from having
unnecessary
angiograms because they actually
you know don't have cardiac injury and
so they go on to have an angio and they
end up with
complications of that and obviously a
normal angio
result which we really shouldn't be
finding
thank you so much dr kellen i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
we have one more question coming in
relating to blood transfusion
how can hospitalites and nursing
utilize it-enabled strategies to
decrease the number of routine
two-unit transfusions to guide providers
to order appropriately
yeah so uh yeah so across canada
actually uh
we've started a campaign which is titled
why give two when one will do
um for the red cell transfusion
and so uh this habit um which is not
based on
any evidence um every single clinical
trial that's been published since 1999
um promoted single-unit red cell
transfusions and despite that
uh when we started our choosing wisely
why give two and one will do
65 of transfusions across canada were
happening as these double unit
transfusions
and so um across our country we have put
out a toolkit
on how to address that specific problem
the way that we um did it at
our hospital is all of our order sets
default to a single unit
so you actually have to go in and change
it to two units and i'm only talking
about inpatients
the way we transfuse outpatients um they
often get two units at a time because
uh we want them to come only once a
month or once every two weeks so we're
really just talking about the impatience
and in addition to pushing them in the
right direction with our computerized
physician order
entry we also have our laboratory
technologists screen every order for an
inpatient as they ask for to
and the patient's not bleeding they get
told i'm sorry that's outside the
guidelines we can give you one unit
and if you repeat the hemoglobin if you
still need
a transfusion based on your laboratory
test results and your clinical
assessment of the patient
then you can go on to have the next unit
when we implemented that at sunnybrook
uh we did that in about 2008
so quite a long time ago we went from
using
18 000 red cells per year at sunnybrook
to 10
000. it is probably one of the most
expensive bad practices uh that you can
possibly have
ari chandra who's done a lot of economic
analysis of
the cost of blood transfusion estimates
that
transfusion costs the system back in
twenty ten dollars was about
seven hundred and forty one dollars per
unit transfused which is a remarkable
expense it probably cost
close to a thousand dollars per patient
today um and so there's
a lot of room to improve on that
you'll also look out for we have a
publication coming out we just did a
multi-center
trial where we had hospitals across the
country
start screening having the text screen
for things like single unit red cell
transfusions and appropriate thresholds
and we were able to uh
reduce the threshold for transfusion
improve the appropriateness
cut down to single unit transfusions and
we saved about
5 000 red cells at
13 hospitals over a 10-month period
and we were able to track mortality and
length of stay
and there was absolutely no harm from
the result of
removing a lot of red cells from those
hospitals
and so i think there's a big room for
improvement in your transfusion practice
thank you so much dr callum we have time
for one more question
how can one support and get involved
with choosing wisely
yeah so um i guess there's like you can
get involved
at your local hospital level and so i
would find out at your local hospital
level
do you have a choosing wisely committee
do you have a laboratory
utilization committee and if you don't
maybe this is your opportunity to start
one
at the national level many countries
have choosing wisely
programs across the country and you can
get involved
in uh across different jurisdictions
and then at the national level there are
committees looking at
trying to push utilization forward even
at our university of toronto recently
they started a laboratory
utilization committee across the whole
you know whatever seven hospitals that
we have
at the university of toronto um to try
and learn from each other
um so we don't kind of repeat um you
know the failures
of other people we learn from other
people's successes
it's also really important if if i'll be
swimming upstream say i'm trying to get
rid of the ck at my hospital
but every other hospital within toronto
is still pushing
that the ck is the right test the
residents are getting one message from
one hospital versus a different message
from my hospital it's certainly going to
help me
be more successful with my intervention
if everybody in my region is
singing from the same song sheet
thank you so much and i want to thank
you for your time today and for your
important research would you like to
provide our
audience members with some final closing
remarks before we go
for sure so uh one i just want to thank
you for
giving me the opportunity to share what
we've done at sunnybrook
i hope you've sort of thought about how
you're going to figure out where to
start your next choosing wisely project
and honestly the best place to start is
sit down with some of your clinicians at
your hospital that are really enthused
about fixing this sit down and have
coffee with them
sit down with them and look at the data
with them and look at those
choosing wisely lists from the american
board of internal medicine
or whatever country that you're in to
figure out where you're going to start
look at your processes you know choose
something that's going to be super easy
you know choose one of the ones that we
did you know the ast the urea the ck the
b12 the vitamin d the hemoglobin a1c
these are really easy wins um
and just choose one or two don't choose
like so many projects you're never going
to get them completed
and get yourself a statistician to help
you analyze that data
and make sure you publish your results
present them at national or
international meetings so that
you know one we get more enthused by
your successes
and we learn from you and globally
across the planet we're going to reduce
our utilization
and really harness a major paradigm
shift in the way that we provide
healthcare
dr callum thank you again for your
presentation and for your important
research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months
till may of 2021 lab routes will alert
you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share this email
with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care stay safe and stay healthy
bye-bye everyone